pflanzenhormone dass es ein thema über
das in zukunft garantiert noch viel mehr
leute sprechen werden weil nämlich
gerade eine neue studie rausgekommen ist
von der ddv die besagt dass
pflanzenhormone und menschliche hormone
sich viel viel ähnlicher sind als man
zunächst dachte und letztes jahr kam
schon bei einer studie raus leute in die
richtung geforscht haben und danach habe
ich dann selber immer im garten ein paar
sachen ausprobiert und die resultate
sind einfach e-mail sind deswegen mache
ich heute mal ein ganzes video nur rund
um das thema pflanzenhormone
diese studie ist eigentlich gar nicht
nur für uns haus kellnerinnen und
hausgärten und super interessant sondern
auch für die ganze welt ernährung wenn
man jetzt herausgefunden hat dass man
auf natürliche art und weise indem man
den pflanzen menschlichen hormone zu
führt die natürlicherweise im urin
enthalten sind das heißt man muss
einfach nur mit urin dünnen dass man auf
die art und weise den ertrag um ein
vielfaches steigern kann sodass ich
hämische dinge hoffentlich bald ein ding
der vergangenheit will und außerdem
enthält der urin selbst auch noch
wichtige pflanzen nährstoffe wie
stickstoff phosphor und kalium und auch
noch ganz viele tolle spurenelemente und
diese kombination aus den hormonen
zusammen mit den wichtigsten
pflanzennährstoffe macht einfach diesen
extremen boost effekt bewiesen ich
erkläre gleich noch wie man das macht
also welchen urin man wann verwendet es
ist ganz wichtig dass man das beachtet
aber was auch wichtig ist der urin
selbst ist zu schade für eure pflanzen
das heißt ihr müsst ihn immer 1 zu 3 mit
wasser verdünnen und viele fragen auch
immer wenn ich die dinger angaben machen
ob ich mal seine faustregel geben kann
wie oft und wie viel man muss also ich
dinge ungefähr so 350 bis 500 milliliter
pro pflanze alle zwei wochen wenn ich
das wachstum so richtig schön fördern
möchte man kann es auch ein bisschen
öfter machen aber ja jetzt nicht
unbedingt täglich weil dann bekommen die
pflanzen auf zu wachstums risse und da
können ein freundes erreger eintreten
und das wäre einfach unschön wenn ihr
euch verraten nur weil es zu verdienen
um einen topf der urin von frauen
enthält vor allem das hormon östrogen
und das kann man ganz gut einsetzen um
die frucht bildung zu verbessern also
bei pflanzen wie tomaten oder auberginen
oder patrick also allen die blühen und
will dann aus der blüte die frucht
entsteht da ist auf jeden fall den urin
von der frau im gebärfähigen alter
verwenden und auch immer zur blüte dann
wartet man bis die tomaten oder die
überwiegend gerade so ihre knospen
bilden und dann kann man mit dem
verdünnten urin dingen um die
fruchtbildung wirklich enorm zu
verbessern ich habe das letztes jahr zum
ersten mal ausprobiert und ich bin euch
jemanden bild 1 von den tomaten die ich
danach geernteten das war unglaublich
jetzt gerade im april stehen im beet ja
aber überhaupt keine gemüse die
irgendwie früchte bilden die tomaten und
so weiter kommen ja erst mitte mai ins
beet und deswegen ist es jetzt viel
wichtiger dass man das allgemeine
wachstum der pflanzen die jetzt gerade
im beet stehen angepöbelt um zum
beispiel beim cool ist es total cool
wenn man jetzt den urin von dem
möglichst männlichen bekannten verwendet
ich bin euch hier meinen bild von den
kürbissen eigentlich letztes jahr mit
meinem urin gelingt habe und dann auch
vom einer zwiebel ernte die wir auch
richtig extrem aber da muss man ein
bisschen unterscheiden weil tomaten und
kürbisse sind ja stark zähler aber
trieben sind schwarz ihrer und ich würde
die sache mit dem urin wirklich nur bei
den mittel und bei den stark zu machen
weil man die schwarze dame ist schon
ordentlich überfordern würde also für
die die es nicht wissen visuell
also schwarz ihrer sind gemüse die fast
keinen dünger brauchen mittels ihrer
bordmittel viel dünger und stark
singapur um die richtige volle dröhnung
und den urin nur den starken mittel zu
ihrer geben bei den schwarz iran gibt es
auch laut dieser studie eine andere
technik die man verwenden kann und zwar
sind auch in den aero sohlen die man aus
atmend genug hormone enthalten um die
zum wachstum anzuregen und deswegen es
ist ja bewiesen schon lange dass
pflanzen besser wachsen wenn man mit
ihnen redet und jetzt weiß man auch
warum das ist nämlich der grund und
deswegen reicht es wenn ihr zwei und
schwach zählern einfach ab und zu ein
paar zärtliche worte für die übrig haben
ein bisschen mit ihnen redet oben eben
das wachstum anzukurbeln
[Musik]
war natürlich nur quatsch also man kann
auf jeden fall mit urin denke ich habe
das bürger selber schon mal gemacht aber
ich würde das nicht auf den salat kippen
weil das ein bisschen eklig ist wenn man
dann direkt die teile ist die von dem
urin sozusagen die netzt wurden also ich
denke damit jan beerensträucher oder
auch mal tomaten aber
das mit den hormonen ist bullshit ja die
hormone sind natürlich ganz
unterschiedliche also
gerade die sexualhormon von von menschen
hier sind jetzt nicht gleich wie das
funktioniert natürlich nicht und vor
allem sind ja auch nicht über die luft
übertragbar
der hat auch angeht kanal aber der post
der gar nicht so viel wie er sollte
eigentlich über fitness konnte hat aber
das liegt ein bisschen stiller moment
kinder wo findet man sich vor allem
instagram unter druck blenden wir hier
unten ein wenn ihr den duell aus tekken
volt und auch fit werden wollt
dann schaut bei ihnen vorbei dann auf
jeden fall im urin von einer frau im
gebärfähigen alter
[Musik]
irgendwo bringt kann die erfolge jetzt
habe ich diese versorgung sachen
zwischendurch geflüchtet ich habe das
[Musik]
dann bin ich weg bereiten